ما ان اطلقت اول رصاصه في مطار الخرطوم
الدولي حتى خسر السودان خمسه في المئه من
اجمالي صادراته ووارداته مليارات دولار من
عائدات صادرات الذهب توقفت هي الاخرى مثل
ما توقفت الحركه التجاريه مع مصر ملايين
الدولارات تتبعثر مع كل قذيفه تفجر مبنى
او تنسف جسرا انها ضريبه الحرب التي
يدفعها المواطنون
المشكله بقى خطيره علينا يا جماعه
المواطنين وعايشين وعايزين
فيها ان لم تهدا المدافع ستدخل البلاد في
فوضى عارمه يحذر الخبراء من مجاعه تطال
الجميع
وحتى ان توقفت الحرب لن يعود التمويل
الدولي بسهوله ولا ثقه المستثمرين ولن
يعود هؤلاء النازحون لدفع عجله التنميه
السودانيه طالما ان بلد الثروات بلا
استقرار سياسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات